it's
a lot firmer than a wooden cane that
people traditionally use um
and it's
yeah leaves some very nice wells which i
love making marks on men's bottoms
[Music]
how did you decide to become a sex
walker
oh that's a good question it started
when i was very young so i was 18 and i
worked in a strip club and
um started out dancing being a stripper
and but previously i've done a lot of
kink in my personal life
and always enjoyed doming
individuals so
yes a long time professionally
a little bit longer
personally what are the usual kind of
things your clients ask you to do
i wouldn't say there is a usual
thing to be honest um people range in
all sorts of different things people's
fantasies and sexualities completely
diff differ from each other
um
i do have quite a reputation for
pegging
anal play and also water sports um so i
do get a lot of clients that request
that
and but i get all sorts of different
requests and some people just want to
have a chat i feel like i get this
question a lot like what's the weirdest
thing you've ever done or what's the
strangest client that you've ever had
honestly everybody's different
so i had um also a younger client that
came to me and
so he sent me an email and he basically
said to me that he'd got this fantasy
that he wanted to
come straight into the dungeon
get gag straight away
uh put on a
hood
a sensory deprivation hood be cuffed
straight away
plugged put straight on the saint
andrews cross
and given a two hour session of impact
play with canes whips bullwhip um
paddles
all over his back everywhere basically
that's what you wanted all of it and i
was like okay that is quite extreme i
basically said to him like what's your
experience
with bdsm and he was like oh this is
just a fantasy for me i've never
actually seen a dom before
i've been watching um a lot of videos
online
so i gave him a call and i was like um
i
yeah i'm happy to go ahead with the
session but um expectation versus
reality in bdsm can be very very
different you know what you might see
and fantasize about is not necessarily
um
what you may enjoy so let's go for the
session and let's take it slowly i can
introduce you to some new implements and
things but um i'd suggest we didn't go
in with the full whole jacking and
sensory hood straight away so you're
able to communicate with me well on what
you're enjoying and also take things off
people's breathing techniques when i'm
doing any impact play of how they're
feeling and give them some time out if
needed
so i did recommend that he didn't you
know
completely um
hud himself and not be able to speak at
that moment and we yeah had a lovely
session and got to explore things with
him but
yeah the difference between fantasy and
reality
it can be yeah massive it's important to
remember what you watch online may not
always be
true well it is true let's say but um
it's taken a lot of training
so when you see your clients where do
you usually where do you usually see
them so i usually do meetings in um
a dungeon that i work in in north london
so we have a queening chair
and which is like a chair that's got a
hole in the middle so
um
you can imagine the lady sits in the
chair the queen or the dom sits in the
chair and the sub sits underneath and
yeah
for it does what he's instructed to do
we also have in there a st andrews cross
which is the
cross that you probably see in i don't
know fifty shades of grey maybe has one
i'm not sure
um but you usually see it as like a
signpost if i don't know bdsm it's like
what everyone has and it's what you can
handcuff the
sub to and hang off their feet too and
it's really good for impact play keep
them on the cross
there's a holding cage in there as well
really useful i always find it a holding
cage useful just in case you're like
faffing about and like finding things in
your bag just put the sub in the holding
cage uh there is a
bed also with straps on it so we do use
that a lot for cotton ball torture
and where you can strap them down
uh facing up and they can be laid on
their back
do you
use any toys um in your job i do i have
lots of toys i've got some with me
actually
this is my delerine cane which is my
favorite because it's
a lot firmer than a wooden cane that
people traditionally use um
and it's
yeah leaves some very nice wells which i
love making marks on men's bottoms
and so
this is yeah just a beautiful denim cane
that is like my go-to cane
is it painful when you when when you do
that yeah it's it is painful yeah
but that's part that's part of the deal
right that is part of the deal yes
okay yeah i've also got um
a
this is my strap-on this is just um
a washable harness because they're easy
to just throw in the washing machine
as opposed to a leather one and i've got
lots of different accessories these are
just a few
and this is my biggest one
which i do have an anal [__] that i call
him
client who loves all things anal and can
take this and a fist also at the same
time so that's quite a lot
and is that is that also attached to the
strap-on yeah this also attaches it's
got a loop in it here and it attaches
yeah
i have some rope
but actually my um
go-to little secret is that i
have shoelaces in my bag
um just little black shoelaces because
they're really handy for tying up like
balls because they're small perfect size
and for what we call cbt which is
cooking ball torture
and so yeah it always looks really
pretty when i tie up a little
balls and it's nice and pink i like it
like that
this would just be used for um bondage
or
um yeah i'm not the best at rope to be
honest there is some people that are at
some dom's programs out there that are
amazing and they do all sorts of shibari
um yeah i just make up my own knots
really
what else have i got in here i've got um
this is a chastity device
yeah so this goes on and then i lock
the penis in here and some guys wear
these for like months at a time and
locked up for a very long time
i also do offer online sessions where i
send these out and
and we do like
monthly lock up and
they get a few video calls and photos
and things like that and it's just an
alternative way to be
uh to submit to me when you can't meet
me in real life
so the idea behind this is that you kind
of suppress your desire
yeah so um it's like a sort of part of
tt's what we call tease and denial
and so if you're locked up obviously you
can't get a hard penis in this
and it's restricting for you and
what else do i have in my bag
um
this is for
yeah just complete sensory deprivation a
lot of clients really like sensory
deprivation this is a really thick
leather hood so you can't really hear
anything in it or see anything obviously
it's got a nice hole there so you can
put my strap on in their mouth
and
and yeah and that also goes with a
jacket that i've got i have a
straight jacket
really beautiful leather straight jacket
if anyone wants to try it on
what kind of clients do you have
well i have clients from
absolutely
everywhere anywhere any kind of line of
work
you know it really varies um
most of my clients are males
um everybody honestly everybody thinks
that i'm going to say like they're all
city boy workers they're all lawyers
they're all businessmen they're not
they're just normal people like me and
you i like that it's really personal and
it's meeting people
and it's got a care aspect to it like 70
of sex workers have actually worked in
care education or voluntary
organizations before
and so and that includes me
i do have some really beautiful stories
um
for example about a man that came out
felt like he could i don't know embraced
his sexuality with me a little bit
so he
was into cross-dressing and loved nylon
tights and wearing women's lingerie
and a lot of the sessions that we had
were based um on dressing him up and
makeup lessons and things like that and
it was a real massive turn on for him
that was his fantasy
and after a couple of sessions
usually clients don't tell you too much
about their home life at first but after
a few sessions he really opened up to me
and he said that you recently got
married
and
that his wife has no idea about these
fantasies that he has which i just
thought was crazy like i think we live
in a world that's full of toxic
masculinity and men are not a be able to
come out about their sexuality as well
as as women or or
you know there's a lot of stigma around
how males should act and be and we've
had kind of a drunken conversation about
that that lasted about an hour
and
he really felt confident to go home and
talk to his wife about
um his
his kinks and he said that that was
really successful and she was very
supportive and that's just a really
sweet story i think
you've kind of talked a lot about all
the things you do to your with your
clients to your clients
are there any things that you wouldn't
do
yeah absolutely um i don't do race play
i don't do scats
i don't do
interrogation
i don't offer
what some sex workers would call full
service which means that um i'm
penetrated by the
and but i mean
some dumbs do it's just dependent and
yeah no judgements for what anyone ever
ever does you know it's all sex work
that we're doing it's just part of my
business model that that's just
something i don't give away
what advice would you give to someone
who's considering a career of a sex
worker so firstly i would say
make sure that your mental health is in
the right place this job can be very
very draining and you're very disposable
as a sex worker
and people are not here your client's
not here to be your friend or
to
text you back or you know they've got
none of that obligation that a
um play partner or boyfriend or a friend
might have and so it can make you feel
very used and disposable at times
especially at first when you're not used
to that
i've also been doing a little bit of
volunteering work for the english
collective prostitutes
and they're an amazing organisation that
campaign for decriminalization of sex
work in the uk
and they also do amazing sex worker
breakfasts on i think it's tuesday
morning
where all kinds of sex workers can go do
lingerie swaps get free condoms
free advice
sexual health
screenings and
yeah they do a lot of amazing things
look them up ecp english collective
prostitutes they're amazing
i think my last probably question would
be are you in a relationship right now
um
i'm quite polly so i have a lot of
different play partners
would you ever see your job as a
potential problem in a relationship
um yes it can be a massive problem
having relationships as a sex worker
and i think it takes a lot of trust and
a very very strong relationship
also
i can't come home at the end of the day
and talk about my work really you know i
don't know that my partner's
boss might be the person i've just seen
um
and it's also very professional for me
to keep all of that
you know quiet which makes it quite
you have to have a lot of trust involved
i think in a relationship like that but
especially because it's of a sexual
nature
it takes a very strong person i think to
date a sex worker
[Music]
we've had accidents on set as well there
are lots of sex accidents that happen
some are minor a scuffed knee or
or someone
being too vigorous with a [__] and
you know kind of biting a little bit
and
and sometimes guys get on